once we're over about 12 years old were
seldom encouraged to be nice we're
expected to make efforts in all kinds of
areas chiefly around work but the idea
of expending energy thinking about and
then practicing the art of niceness
sounds bizarre even eerie
that's why we've drawn up a checklist of
10 virtues that we think matter more
than ever in the modern age resilience
this is the art of keeping going even
when things are looking dark of
accepting reversals as normal of
refusing to frighten others with one's
own fears and of remembering that human
nature is in the end reassuringly tough
empathy the capacity to connect
imaginatively with the sufferings and
unique experiences of another person the
courage to become someone else and look
back at oneself with honesty patience we
lose our temper because we believe that
things should be perfect we've grown so
good in some areas like putting men on
the moon wherever less able to deal with
things that still insist on going wrong
at traffic government other people we
should grow calmer and more forgiving by
getting more realistic about how things
actually tend to go sacrifice we're
hardwired to seek our own advantage but
also have this miraculous ability very
occasionally to forego our own
satisfactions in the name of someone or
something else we won't ever manage to
raise a family love someone else or save
the planet if we don't keep up with the
art of sacrifice politeness politeness
has a bad name we often assume it's
about being fake which is meant to be
bad as opposed to really ourselves which
is meant to be good how
given what most of us are really like
deep down we should spare others too
much exposure to our deep ourselves we
need to learn manners which aren't evil
they're the necessary internal rules of
civilization politeness is very linked
to tolerance to a capacity to live
alongside people whom one won't
necessarily agree with but at the same
time won't be able to avoid humour
seeing the funny sides of situations and
of one's self doesn't sound very serious
but it's integral to wisdom because it's
a sign that once been able to put a
benevolent finger on the gap between
what we want to happen and what life can
actually provide like anger humor
springs from disappointment but its
disappointment optimally channeled it's
one of the best things we can do with
our sadness self-awareness to know
oneself is to try not to blame others
for one's troubles and moods to have a
sense of what's going on inside oneself
and what actually belongs to the world
forgiveness forgiveness means a long
memory of all the times when we wouldn't
have got through life without someone
cutting us some slack it's recognizing
that living with others isn't possible
without excusing errors
hope the way the world is now is only a
pale shadow of what it could one day be
was still only at the beginning of
history as you get older
despair becomes far easier almost reflex
whereas in adolescence it was still cool
my adventurous pessimism isn't
necessarily deep nor optimism shallow
confidence the greatest projects and
schemes died for no grander reason that
we don't dare confidence isn't arrogance
it's based on constant awareness of how
short life is and how little we
ultimately lose from risking everything
let's try to keep these in mind and
practice them a little every day
you